ah the screen is on and you can hear me
fantastic okay people will keep coming
in for a minute but I'll probably get
started and so hello everyone nice to
see you thank you for coming here I hope
this is going to be a fun way to end the
first day of the conference for you so
my name is Steve and I work on this
thing this blazer product so I'm on the
asp net team at Microsoft and we've been
developing blazer for a couple of years
now and it's kind of released and kind
of not released but we'll talk more
about that in a minute
just so I can tailor my introduction to
you a little bit can you do our quick
hands up if you feel that you know what
blazer is about like you've heard the
big idea like okay so almost everyone
alright um and also for my personal
interests
hands up if you've actually used it or
tried it out in any way that's alright
that's pretty much half of the people
here so that's pretty cool so it's
becoming a little bit tricky to decide
how to do talks about blazer because
we're at the point now where so many
people know about the basics that you
can't really just do a whole talk about
that but at the same time there's still
quite a lot of people that need to catch
up so the kind of middle ground that I
want to strike in this talk to set your
expectations is for about the first 15
minutes or so 10 to 15 minutes we're
going to go through some of the basic
ideas like what's the point of this
thing why does it exist what does it
look like what can you do with it
and we'll do a bit of programming in
some simple cases and then after that
for the remaining part of the talk we'll
go into some more advanced scenarios and
we'll look at some future things that we
haven't actually shipped yet some cool
experimental things that we're working
towards so you can get a sense of where
this is going so to start off with this
little intro section let me give you a
quick history lesson so I want you to
think back in time cast your minds back
like as far as you can possibly remember
your earliest memories it's like 2017 or
there abouts
and think about what it was like back
then back in those days if you were
trying to make a rich web application
show up in someone's browser well if you
wanted it to be interactive in any way
you would have to use one of these
things so you'd be using something like
angular or react or view and you would
be building what is basically a
JavaScript application and maybe you
think well yeah my code wasn't actually
JavaScript back then and was using
typescript or flow or something else
well yeah that's cool but that does
compile to JavaScript so at runtime the
semantics of your application are
JavaScript and that's just the way
things were and that's fine people were
very successful and they're led happy
and fulfilled lives with that but it's
kind of a shame if the only language
that you can use is just one thing cuz
you know software is a rich world we've
got many different kinds of languages
frameworks tool chains and the web would
be a richer place if there were more
options available and so that's why this
exciting little thing came onto the
scene at the start of 2017 which is
webassembly a bytecode format for the
web so it's a new type of code that can
run in a browser it's not JavaScript
it's a kind of byte code that you can
compile to from whatever sort of
language or ecosystem you want as long
as you can compile to web assembly you
can run inside the browser so back then
at the start of 2017 when this was
happening quite a lot of people started
getting excited with ideas like well
does this mean that we could run dotnet
inside a browser again but this time
without any sort of plugins just in a
pure standards-compliant way and I was
one of the people who got very excited
about that I started doing some
prototyping and I thought actually yeah
there is a way that we can do this we
can make applications run inside a
browser we need three ingredients to
make this work and the ingredients are
one web assembly which is great because
we've got that in fact we've had that
for you know two to three years now this
has been shipping a standard in all
up-to-date browsers both desktop and
mobile so that's basically a solved
problem the next thing we need is some
kind of dotnet runtime so what I found
to my surprise and delight that without
very much work it was possible to
compile a dotnet runtime to web assembly
and once you've done that you can load
normal dotnet assemblies into it and
execute them inside your browser which
is amazing if the only thing you want to
do is print messages to the console
which is not exactly what I wanted to do
I had slightly broader
aspirations that I wanted to build
actual rich you eyes and so that needed
a UI framework and that's where this
thing comes in blazer so blazer is a UI
framework for dotnet it's not the
ability to run dotnet on web assembly
that's a separate thing blazer is a UI
framework and it can run on web assembly
but it can run in other places too so if
you are running in a browser and web
assembly then because you're already
there in the browser you can build a UI
just by having blazed a call-out to the
Dom API for you and that's just gonna
work and this is the original hosting
model for blazer
it's called client-side blazer or blazer
webassembly as we call it now that's the
original type of blazer but it's not the
only type because while we were doing
this we realize that we've got something
pretty flexible here and we can run your
blazer applications in other ways as
well
so another thing that we could do is we
could take your blazer components and we
could run them on a server in a cloud
somewhere and then when they want to
render some UI into someone's browser
well they can reach out across the
Internet through a real-time WebSocket
signal our connection and cause the UI
to appear there inside people's browsers
and that is server-side laser so we're
going to be talking a little bit more in
this talk about the differences between
these two models and why you should pick
one or the other depending on your
situation but before we really get to
that I want to start looking at some
code cuz we haven't done any coding yet
and I've had enough for some slides so
let's have a go at building an actual UI
using the blazer programming model and
the scenario I want to take on is budget
allocation okay sounds unbelievably
boring but imagine the situation right
the situation is this next week you go
back to your company and you adopt
blazer and as an immediate result of
that you inevitably become dramatically
more successful okay and then following
on from that is a another immediate
result you have loads more money than
you ever did before which is one of the
problems there you know we can all
relate to and so we have to decide then
what we're going to do with all this
extra money we need to somehow give it
out to all the staff as bonuses but who
gets the bonuses how much do they get
well that's the budget allocation
problem that we're going to solve and
there are this is a real-world problem
people try to build you eyes to do this
kind of thing and an example of a real
world
ui4 budget allocation is this so I got
this picture off the internet it's it's
the humble jumbo bundle three just a
snappy name and when you buy that you
get to choose how your money gets
distributed across these different
budget items so how about we try and
build something like that
using the blazer programming model just
now and then we'll get a sense of what
it's like to use so I'm going to switch
over to my IDE and you can see I'm using
Visual Studio and when there's windows
here but you don't have to do that you
can equally well use vs code on Linux or
Mac or and windows if you want you can
use vs for Mac if you like and I'm just
gonna use vo some windows because I'm
familiar with that and this is my
application I'm gonna start it up first
and then we'll look at a little bit of
the code inside there so if I run it
you'll see this may be familiar to many
of you certainly those of you who have
seen blazer before this is pretty much
the default file new project that you
get when you create a new blazer project
and it's got a few pages in there it's
got some example stuff like at this
button that you can click on and it
counts it an example affecting some data
from the server and that's very well but
it's kind of boring and I don't want to
talk about it too much because I've
talked about a million times and you can
see plenty of information about this on
the internet already so what I want us
to look at really is this bonus splitter
page that we're going to implement so
where's the code for that then well this
is the project here and let's get the
hang on that way all right so this is a
blazer application in this case it's a
blazer server application so my code
here is going to be running on the
server and it's going to be updating the
UI dynamically over a socket connection
but you won't really be able to tell
that's happening because it's very fast
but the same code would work equally
well on blazer webassembly doesn't
really make much difference now what
have we got in here what is the code
well it's a bunch of c-sharp files and
RAZR files so razor files are the
components in a blazer application and
blazer is a component UI framework you
build a set of components that contain
other components it's just a big tree of
components all the way down and the one
we want to work on is this bonus dot
razor and you can see doesn't have very
much in there right now the only
interesting thing really we've got is
this page directive
says this is the thing that will be
displayed if you are at the URL bois de
bonus and that is indeed the URL that I
map so that's why that markup is getting
displayed okay so let's put some logic
in here now because this is a razor file
I can put in some c-sharp code that will
run wherever my application is running
and I want to model the idea of this
this budget situation so what we gonna
do well let's start by defining the
total amount of money that we're trying
to allocate and we're gonna say we'll
have a million pounds that we need to
give out dollars or whatever units of
currency you like and I need to know who
are the candidates for receiving this
money so I've defined this class called
budget item which has got a name and an
amount and we're going to set up a list
of them so we can model our scenario
okay so we want to give some money to
developers some to managers and some to
salespeople and now I can use that to
write a little bit of UI so up here in
my razor markup I can start writing out
some normal HTML so I'm never div with
class equals budget and if I want to
make a list of things well I can use a
normal C sharp for each statement so for
each of our item in budget items we can
omit some markup to those and the markup
that I'm going to omit is going to look
like this so for each thing I'm gonna
display the name and the amount of money
which is formatted as currency with zero
decimal places and then we'll just have
this little to-do message over here so
let's run that now and see if that
actually does render something so we
reload and yes okay
can you still hear me okay yeah okay
sounds weird to me up here right so we
can see we've got these three categories
now developers managers and sales
they've got no money and we need to make
an editor and the kind of editor that we
want to make if you remember looks like
this so we want to have these horizontal
sliders and the way we can do sliders in
HTML is to use the input type equals
range input type equals range and if you
want to use one of these it starts at
zero and you need to specify a maximum
value that it goes up to and I'm going
to
goes up to the total budget we can also
specify the minimum increments step so
we don't need to go up in individual
pounds or fractions of pounds honestly
we've got so much money now we don't
care about any unit that's less than a
thousand pounds at a time and then
finally we need to put this data
somewhere so I'm gonna use Blazers
built-in bind to set up a two-way
binding between this slider and the
amount that's on my item like that okay
let's try that out and see if we built a
nice budget editor okay so we've got
these sliders and it does actually
update the values on our underlying
model which is cool but it's not very
cool just yet
actually it's pretty awful right now
it's nearly impossible to enter any
specific amount of money because you see
that the numbers don't even update until
I release the mouse so that's pretty
terrible why is that well that is
because Blazer is built on normal web
technologies and let the bind attribute
here that is by default connected to the
browser's change event on that element
and if you know web programming you may
know that the change event will only
fire when the user moves away from the
component or when they let go of their
mouse on a slider so that's not the
event I want to listen to I want to
listen to a different event which is
standard in the browser and I can do
that by saying the bind event I want to
listen for is on input okay so let's see
what effect that has now on the UI so
now as I move these sliders you'll see
that the number now updates in real time
which is a lot better but we still got a
series of UX problems with this but one
of them is how do I know when I've
allocated all the money like I maybe I
don't know whether that adds up to a
million or not my my arithmetic is not
that good
so let's display the amount of money
that remains to be allocated and we can
do this quite easily so NC shop we can
define a property called remaining and
we'll compute that by starting with the
total budget and we'll subtract the sum
of all the items that we've assigned so
far and then we can display that on the
screen inside a span like this the
remaining amount is that formatted as a
currency okay let's see if that
makes things a little better now so
we've got a million remaining and as we
move this that amount goes down so
that's pretty good
but we've still got more problems for
example nothing stops our user right now
allocating even more money than they've
actually got like I've done yeah so how
can I stop them from doing that make
sure they don't over spend their budget
well I want to change the maximum value
that you're allowed to assign and what
I'm going to say is for each item you
are allowed to assign the the amount
that you have already assigned to that
Plus at most the remaining amount okay
hopefully that makes sense you've
already got this much and this is how
much is remaining maximally when you are
editing this particular thing so let's
see the effect of that now and I warn
you it's pretty weird at this point so
let's see I'm gonna give quite a lot of
money to developers because obviously
they're great and then I'll start
assigning some money to the managers and
watch what happens okay so if I move it
right up to the end well
okay so it's good in the sense that I
wasn't able to exceed my budget anymore
and I fact I can't even assign any money
to the salespeople now because you know
there's nothing left but it's also like
mad because these two sliders they
appear to be in the same place so you'd
think they represent the same amount of
money but they don't they represent
different amounts because the scale
factors have changed now depending on
how I edited it so what I'm going to do
is a cool little trick which is maybe
hard to understand at first but just go
with me I want to change the horizontal
scale of these elements so that they
compensates for the different max values
that I'm assigning to them so don't
worry if you don't quite follow this
code you can think about it later and
ponder on the maths behind it it's not
too bad so we're saying the width of
each item is going to be in proportion
to the maximum amount that could be on
that item so even if you don't quite
follow that hopefully you'll appreciate
the effect let's see what happens now so
as I move the developers amount you'll
see that the remaining space on the
other ones goes down now to compensate
for it so if there's only a small amount
of money left there's only a very small
slider that I can set up for the sales
people which is cool and I quite like
this as a UX because it really makes you
think carefully about
what you're doing so if you decide that
you need to give more money to one group
you have to think first about where
you're taking it away from so in this
case I would say well you know these
people at the bottom they're not really
adding any value so let's move that down
there and then you know we can put it
where it where it belongs okay that's
good so we've made a pretty decent
little user experience here but there's
still one problem left at least maybe
several but at least one and that's why
if our user is not being very smart
today and they just don't even allocate
all the money and they're just leaving
some money on the table for no reason at
all how can we stop them from doing that
well let's say that we want to have a
Save button at the bottom of our UI so
I'm gonna have a button with the
captions save and I'm not gonna wire up
any behavior to it but what I will say
is that this button will be disabled if
the remaining amount is greater than
zero it's a very simple and intuitive
way of controlling the state of that
button come back and reload and you'll
see that the Save button is disabled
right now but if I allocate all the
money then it becomes enabled disabled
enabled disabled enabled and we've
hopefully achieved our goals there so
we've created something that's quite a
lot like this real world example and
we've done so in pretty straightforward
and intuitive code not very much code
the only difficult bit about is this
weird expression on style there so I
hope that gives you a sense of what the
Blazer programming model looks like and
how it allows you to combine normal HTML
normal Dom type features with some
c-sharp and then we can run that
wherever we want whether it's on the
server or whether it's inside web
assembly the other bit about blazer that
I've not really got into just yet is the
fact that it's a component based
framework so we've only been working on
this one component and we're not really
showing you how we can split stuff up
into lots of components and reuse them
from each other and to do that I want to
move on to a slightly bigger a more
interesting example so that previous
application was running on blazer server
and now want to move on to a bigger
scenario that's going to be running on
blazer webassembly and as we do that
I'll show you some cool features that
are not actually part of the framework
yeah but things that we're thinking
about including in the future and
hopefully you can give us some feedback
about
so what will the scenario be well I
thought it would be quite fun to do some
things that doesn't actually even run
inside a normal computer at all
something that doesn't run inside a
normal browser I would like to do
something that runs on a specialized bit
of hardware just for a change and the
scenario that came to mind for me was
this so how many of you have ever used
one of these devices in your actual
lives yeah so they're not that unusual
they've been around for a few years now
this photo is from Waitrose but I think
I've already also seen them in ASDA so
don't worry it's not just a middle-class
thing you can even use them if you're
from up north like me and if you're not
familiar with this the way it works is
you go into the supermarket and you're
going to do some shopping but you're an
impatient person and you don't want to
go to the checkout at the end because
standing in line is just the worst thing
that you can do so what happens instead
is you go into the supermarket and near
the entrance you see this big Bank of
devices and you walk over and you pick
one of them up and it turns on and then
while you're going around the
supermarket doing your shopping each
time you want to buy something you scan
its barcode with your scanner and the
device displays a list of items that are
in your trolley right now and it shows
you the price the amount that you spent
altogether and then when you finish
doing your shopping and you're ready to
go home you don't have to go and stand
in line and wait for someone to scan all
your stuff all you do now is you go over
to the payment area and you scan your
order onto the payment machine you put
your card in you pay and you walk out
and you didn't have to queue up so
that's that's the scenario and what
we're gonna do in the next 20 minutes or
so
is build some of the UI that would run
on one of these devices and hopefully as
we go I'll be able to give you a few
reasons why blazer webassembly would
actually be a really good fit for this
in the real world okay
so let's switch over to the application
that we're going to be working on now
obviously we don't have time to build
that completely from scratch right now
so I've already started preparing a
starting point for us here and what have
I got in this solution then well I've
got three projects in here but ignore
the test one for now we'll get to that
later we've got the server to client I'm
just gonna start up my serve
and I know that's kind of hard to to
make sense of but there we go
alright so the server in this case is
the thing that's responsible for having
all the product inventory data so
there's too much data for us to actually
put on one of these little devices so
there's going to be some kind of
back-end server that our client
application to make requests to to get
information about whatever Goods the
user has scanned and that can be updated
you know whenever we want now as it
happens I've implemented it with a
subpoena core but I didn't have to I
could have used any server-side
technology we want for that because
Blaser as a client doesn't really care
what your server is but you know I'm
kind of familiar with it's been at core
so that's why I've chosen to do that and
then I've also got blazer client and
this is a blazer webassembly
application and inside there we've got
basically the same stuff that we had in
our other application which was running
on the server so we've got the same kind
of razor files and c-sharp files and
inside there we're going to be doing the
same component or intent programming so
let's just try starting this up and see
what it looks like before we look at
some code so if I launch that in my
browser now you'll see we get this
blazer Mart and it's ready to go
so I user can now start using it now if
you remember in the real world the
display will probably be sort of a
portrait orientation like this or
something but we don't really care about
that that's just a matter of CSS so for
the rest of this talk will just continue
displaying it full screen in landscape
mode and as you can see the only feature
of our application that we want to
expose to users is the ability to scan
groceries now I've also got this
autocomplete thing that I'll show you
later but we wouldn't have that in the
real world in the real world users are
just going to be using a barcode scanner
so to get a sense of what that's
actually like I've got a barcode scanner
and I've got some groceries such as this
tin of beans so if I scan the barcode on
this beans you can see that immediately
my application jumps into life and it
says ok you've scanned something and
it's started to work but it's not really
working correctly yeah you can see it
says fake product instead of telling me
what I actually scanned and so how does
any of this work let's see some of the
code that's behind there and I'd say the
best place to start with understanding
this
is this component that I've created
called appraiser that's my top level
root component in this application and
if we look in there you'll see that
we've got a series of other things so up
at the top we've got this search box
that's obviously corresponds to the
thing up there on the screen and then
below that we're doing the same thing
that we did in the budget example where
we're using a normal for each loop to
say for each of the things in your cart
we're going to display this other
component that I've created called cart
row display and then below that if
there's anything in your cart will
display a footer so you may remember
that initially there was nothing in my
car and I didn't have any footer on the
screen and so this if test was false but
when I come along and I scan something
then that test will become true and the
item will become part of the UI okay
pretty straightforward stuff but why
does it say fake product that doesn't
really seem right well let's see what
the flow is when this when you scan an
item so our search box will raise this
custom event or callback called item
chosen and I've wired that up here to
this handle item chosen method and down
here you can see that and it receives an
enormous tree and is literally just the
number that's printed at the bottom of a
barcode so that's what the barcode
scanner is providing to us here and
that's all we know about what this scans
so far and then we're going to try and
add that to their car so I factored out
the logic to that for that into this
domain type called cart which is just a
normal see Sharpe method see shop class
and if we have a look inside there then
let's see what that thing actually does
okay so you can see that I've got a
little bit of business logic it's kind
of boring stuff and I don't want to get
into it too much my logic is if you've
already got one of these in your cart
then we'll increase the quantity of it
and if you haven't then we're going to
start fetching it from the server and
you can see I've got this retry loop
we'll talk more about that later the
relevant bit right now is this but this
is where we're going to actually fetch
some data from the server and as you can
see it's all very fake right now so
we're just waiting a little bit to
pretend that we're doing some meta
data access and then we returning this
fake data so how can we actually get
real data from the back-end server
well there's one very straightforward
and obvious way which is probably
something that you've most of you have
done probably many times in your careers
if you want to get data from a server
there's a good chance that you would
make an HTTP request to it and you would
have it return some JSON data to you and
that's great that absolutely works it's
very straightforward it's by far the
most common way of doing this kind of
data access from Blaise a web sembly up
or any other kind of spa and that's
great but there are some drawbacks to
doing this kind of Jason over at DDP
kind of approach today to access one of
the drawbacks is that JSON is not a very
efficient way of representing data is a
very verbose way of representing data
that's designed for humans and it's not
even got all that much control of a
precision of certain things like numbers
and dates and such so is it's not
necessarily the most efficient way that
we could represent our data on the wire
and the other thing is when you make
these requests how do you know what URL
to make the request to and even if you
know the URL how do you know what HTTP
method to use and even if you know that
when the response comes back do you know
what the different status codes might be
and what they're supposed to mean well
maybe you do but it's quite a lot to
manage and there's no real formal system
for tracking all this it's kind of a
very much alike at an informal best
efforts kind of system so you might
think well hasn't anybody invented a
better way of doing this isn't there
perhaps a more modern way of connecting
my client and my back-end server in a
more performant and strongly-typed way
and the answer to that is yeah
absolutely there are loads of ways you
can do that people soap soap it's one of
them yeah we could do so people have
invented many different ways of doing
that over the years and one of them that
has really started to get a lot of
traction recently anyone guess what I'm
going to say GFP C so the S peanut team
did a lot of work in the three Oh time
frame to make G RPC work really well on
a spinet course server and just in the
last week we've announced some
experimental preview packages that give
you support for G RPC web now G apply C
web is a subset or a slight variation on
G RPC that you could
use from browser-based applications and
I've got a browser-based application
here so how about we have a go at doing
some G RPC from our client application
okay so how can we do that well on the
server I've already got a little bit of
G RPC stuff going on if we look in this
proto's directory you can see inventory
dot proto and that's how we define a G
RPC service proto is a language
independent format for describing a set
of endpoints that can be called and it's
strongly typed and it does some cool
stuff for you for example you can
automatically code generate code that
can be run on the server and the client
to wire all this stuff up together now
at the moment I've only got one endpoint
it's called autocomplete and that's the
thing that is replying if I start typing
into this box up here so I can just you
know start adding stuff from the drop
from the drop down you wouldn't have
that in the real world but it's kind of
helpful during development to be able to
just type stuff and not use a barcode
scanner all the time anyway I want to
get real Product data from the server
now so I'm going to add a new endpoint
on the server and I'm going to define it
like this it's called product details it
will take a product details request and
return the product details response and
I haven't defined those yet so let's do
that
my definition will look like this the
request will be the article number from
the client that's all and then the
response will be a product pretty
straightforward stuff okay so let's
build that now and once I've done that I
can start filling in a server-side
implementation for it and like I said
this is designed to tie-in with code
generation so on the server you'll see
I've got this class already called
inventory service which inherits from
inventory base and that is automatically
provided for me by the tooling which
means now if added the new endpoint I
can type override and you'll see that
intelligence says hey why don't you
consider supplying some logic for
product details okay so I will what
logic do I want on the server well I can
do something pretty simple I can do the
following
I can say ok this is going to be a sync
for a start I'm gonna add a bit of a
delay because if I don't it's all gonna
be too fast and you won't be able to see
the loading states that we're going
through so we'll just do that
then we'll do a lookup in the database
to get the product object and we can
return that to the client and that's all
there is to it on the server great so
now I've changed my server I'm going to
have to restart that and then I want to
put some logic into the client to
actually call it and that's pretty
straightforward too because again we are
able to make use of this code generation
stuff so if I go into my cart data type
here my domain object you'll see that in
the constructor I'm receiving from the
dependency injection system an instance
of inventory client and that is code
generated I don't have to write that and
if I go down here I can now call a
method on it so let's get rid of all
this fake logic here and we'll see what
methods are on the inventory client well
you'll see that we've got autocomplete
and autocomplete async but what's
happened to our product details why
don't we have that surely we should by
now well I didn't recompile so that
hasn't been regenerated yet but now
every compiled you'll see now we've got
autocomplete and we've got product
details and we can call that from our
client so the logic we're going to want
on the client looks a bit like this we
are going to construct a product details
request with that article number we will
make a request to the server and we'll
get the product back out of the response
so let's see what happens now and
whether this stuff actually works so
I'll come back over here and I'm going
to scan my beans again and this time
what do we get we get beans so it
actually works we've got our server and
our client talking GRP see yeah
and so my user can now go around and do
the rest of their shopping so in case
you're wondering I'm working on a bit of
an experimental dessert recipe right now
so with my beans I want to wrap them
delicately in a parcel of ready to roll
icing and then to really bring out the
flavors I'm gonna need a bit of this
Thai fish sauce which I think will go
really well but actually I'm just going
to need just a bit more of that to
really you know make the flavors a pop
okay so we have been able to make our
bigger application there speak G RPC
between the client and the server and we
get some benefits from that like we've
got much more efficient network traffic
now and we get this strongly type
interoperability between the server and
I claim
excuse me okay so let's move off on that
to the next subject that I want to talk
about and this is going to be to do with
testing which it's clearly a very
important subject if you want to write
some high quality software and one of
our design goals for blazer from the
very beginning has been to make sure
that you can test your blazer components
in a very productive and satisfying kind
of way so how could you do that well
traditionally there's two main
approaches that you could use for
testing some kind of UI component you
could do unit level testing because
Blazer components are just classes so
you could use a normal unit testing
framework to new up an instance of your
component and then start calling methods
on him and that's cool but it's quite
low level and it doesn't give you any
way of interacting with the rendered
output you can't say I want to simulate
clicking on a button or something
because there aren't even any buttons so
that doesn't you know it's very
low-level way of doing testing the other
more high-level way you could do it is
to do some kind of browser automation
using something like selenium which is
something that we do a lot on the team
that's building this because we need to
check that the framework actually works
so we've got a lot of experience of
setting up this very big suite of
selenium based browser automation tests
and it's all very good in the sense that
it's high level and you can work in
terms of CSS selectors and clicking on
buttons and things but it does have the
drawback that these tests tend to be
quite slow to execute it can take maybe
a full second to execute each test and
unless you're very careful about how you
do it is easy to fall into the trap of
making tests that are a bit flaky
because they accidentally depend on some
details of the order in which things are
rendered all the timings of things and
we've had to fight with that quite a lot
so this gets us thinking can we design
something that gives you a way of
testing your components that has got the
speed and robustness of unit tests
combined with the kind of high-level
expressiveness that you get with browser
automation so let's have a look at an
experimental version of something like
that
so I've got here this third project
called laser mark test and I'm going to
load that and if we look in there you'll
see I've got this test class called car
tests and it's going to be using X unit
as the test framework and I'm also using
this experimental thing called test hope
and what that allows me to do is say I
want to mount an instance of my
component in this test environment it's
not an actual browser but we're going to
be able to simulate what happens in
terms of rendering and user interactions
okay so you'll remember this app
component from earlier app is the root
component of my application so I'm
basically testing the whole thing I
could test individual components at once
or I can test complete groups of
applications just whatever a level of
the tree I choose to use as the entry
point so here here I'm testing the whole
thing and I'm saying that if we look for
all the elements with the cart item
class we won't find any because by
default the car is empty that's why I'm
testing here okay
the next test is a bit more detailed
this is going to test what happens when
the user scans something so just like
before we get an instance of our test
component our app component and this
time I'm going to do a bit of fancy
mocking stuff where I'm going to
intercept any requests that are made to
the backend so that I can simulate
different kinds of responses coming back
or in this case I'm gonna simulate there
is no response let's come back and then
I want to simulate what happens when the
user scan something now if you were
wondering how this barcode scanner
actually works before all it is is it
just simulates a keyboard so if I scan
if I scan these beams right now then in
my IDE you'll see the number gets typed
out by that so that's all the barcode
scanner is doing and I can simulate that
same action by typing into this search
input a fake
EAN okay then I submit the form just by
pressing enter like the barcode scanner
does and then I can say okay if we look
for the cart items now it's not gonna be
empty anymore there will be one and it
will say loading on it okay that sounds
believable right and then thirdly and
finally we can simply can test what will
happen when the server replies so I'm in
the same situation as before except this
time I'm going to simulate the server
replying with this particular data and
now I can check that inside the UI that
particular product name has shown up on
a certain element in the rendered output
okay so let's see if this stuff actually
works shall we
these are standard dotnet unit tests so
they will run in any dotnet test Runner
for example you can run them
inside the test Runner that's built into
vs or on the command line whatever you
like and I'm running them now it has to
compile and then it runs and you can see
that they've all passed and the nice
thing about this is that it's very fast
so the first one might take a little
while to get started up because you know
it's still jetting and all that but once
it gets going they're really really fast
so we're talking single-digit
milliseconds here and it's going to be
very robust because there's no out of
process activity at all it's all
completely synchronous in process you
shouldn't get flaky behaviors okay so
that's nice but can we use this to
actually aid our development process in
any practical way for example does this
mean that we can now do test-driven
development well I'm not claiming that
you always should do tests of and
development or necessarily think you
even ever should I'm not giving you any
opinion about that right now
all I'm saying is if you did want to do
that sort of thing then hopefully the
tooling and the platform and all the
libraries that we've given to you should
support whatever workflow you want so
let's imagine that we do want to do a
bit of test-driven development right now
and the feature I want to add is this
one this remove item button you'll
notice that if I click this button right
now I'm clicking it nothing happens at
all because I haven't implemented
anything just yet so what behavior would
we want to have well for UX that I want
around removing is if the user wants to
remove an item I don't want them to be
able to just pick from the screen which
item they're removing because if they do
that they might make a mistake and
remove the wrong item and then they'll
get completely confused and they'll just
have a disaster in the in the shop so
what I want them to do instead is when
they say they want to remove stuff I
want them to have to scan the item that
they're taking out of their trolley so
you know the CCTV people can watch and
see that they scan and then they put it
back and they really did actually put it
back yeah that's how it actually works
in the shops as well so I want when I
click on the remove item button for the
whole UI to switch into a different mode
which is about removing stuff now and
then they scan and then it will switch
back into the normal mode so that's
quite a complicated UX flow there and
since that's a bit complicated I'm going
to feel better if I can define that
using tests so I'm going to start by
defining another test just now and it's
going to be called can
remove item and for this test again
we'll simulate being in this situation
where there's an item in the cart and
then I'm going to write some assertions
so I'm going to say that by default
there won't be any overlay covering the
screen because how I'm going to
implement this is when you go into this
remove mode there's going to be an
overlay that fills the whole screen and
displays a message but we're not in that
mode by default so that should be null
and if we run this test now should it
pass any opinions quick no yes people
say yes and they are right because there
is no overlay by default
I haven't implemented that so it's going
to pass okay so following this
test-driven counter process I'm going to
add some more assertions until they
start failing so this time I'm going to
simulate clicking on the remove item
button and now this overlay should not
be null anymore it should be there I
should be on the screen and there should
be some text in it that says scan an
item to remove and if I run the tests
again now well this time we don't expect
it to pass because we certainly haven't
implemented any of that stuff just yet
so this time when it runs the test fails
and does it give us a good explanation
well it says the element does not have
an event handler for the event on click
OK and the actual line of code that is
throwing that is this one here so you
can see it makes sense right you're
trying to click on this item
but that item doesn't even listen for
clicks so it makes no sense and we're
just going to fail the test so I'm gonna
go over it now to this remove item
button and I'm gonna put in an actual
click handler so I'm gonna use at on
click because the handler is gonna be a
dotnet handler and not like that which
could be a JavaScript one and inside
there I'm gonna say let's call a method
called enter remove mode all right now
I'm gonna have to define that method
otherwise the IDE and the compiler will
start complaining at me as you can see
look that doesn't exist so let's define
this method and what is it going to do
well it's going to do a pretty simple
thing I'm just going to set a flag to
true and I haven't actually defined that
flag yet so let's do that okay and
that's all for now let's see how far
test starts passing so we'll run the
test again and this time we know there
is a click handler so it shouldn't fail
for the same reason Atlee
and this time does it pass no it still
fails and this time it says there was a
not null assertion failure on this line
here so again it makes sense they
overlay did not appear so the test
should fail all right let's make the
overlay appear this time so again using
normal razor syntax I'm gonna say if
we're in the remove mode I'm gonna
display an overlay with this markup
inside it now if you are wondering what
overlay is is this a built in framework
feature no it is not it's a very simple
component that I've put in my
application here called overlay and it
just renders this div with this class of
overlay and it puts whatever child conte
inside that you want and in this case
the content I want is this paragraph
here so let's try running our test yet
again well it's passive this time well
let's see after it recompiles then this
time it does pass good all right great
so we're making some progress but this
is not the whole Fleur that I want to
test I want to test what happens now if
we scan an item while we're in the
remove mode so let's add a little bit of
logic for that I'm going to say alright
I'll simulate the barcode scanner in the
same way that I did before scanning the
same item that we've got in the cart and
this time we should say that the cart
has now become empty because we removed
the thing for it and then the overlay
should go away as well let's run the
test yet again and see whether it passes
now of course it should not because we
haven't implemented the actual removal
feature so it doesn't so let's implement
that right now how is that going to work
well I'm gonna change my handle item
chosen a little bit I'll say if in
remove mode is in remove mode then we'll
do something and if we're not then we'll
do what we were doing before and the
logic I'm going to have now is cart dot
remove item and we'll pass that article
number through to there and we can say
then the is in remove mode can go back
to being false so that we're not in that
mode anymore okay so as far as I'm aware
we've now implemented this feature
correctly so let's try that out and see
if our test is any happier this time and
the answer is
the test passes great so we've now
implemented this removed feature and we
know it works because the unit test says
so we don't even need to look at it in a
browser because we have that much
confidence right no I actually do want
to see it I'm sure you want to see it as
well so let's try it now let's say I've
got some beans and some fish sauce then
I've killed my web server so that's not
so good at it let's bring that back up
so look you come and now I'm going to
scan my things again there and there and
I decided that I don't really need those
beans because Thai fish sauce is
nutritious enough on its own so we'll
get rid of the beans and you can see it
actually works so excellent alright so
that is about testing and there's a
third area that I want to go onto now so
another area that we haven't actually
shipped anything useful for but we are
planning to do so by the time this stuff
ships which won't be too long is around
progressive web applications or PWS so
that's a pretty hot area in the
front-end world at the moment has been
for a year or two and these PWA api's
are ways of doing desktop like things
from inside a web browser and the most
famous thing that you can do with the
PWA api's is make your application work
offline that's kind of the headline
feature for PWA is in general and that
would actually be really useful for us
with this application because how does
these devices work anyway well
presumably they work by connecting to
the in-store Wi-Fi so Wi-Fi is not 100%
reliable
what happens if a shopper comes into the
shop they pick up one of these devices
and they're about to start using it but
at that very moment it can't connect to
the Wi-Fi what's the user experience
going to be like in that case well we
can find out we can simulate it so I'm
going to tell my browser to simulate
being offline and we'll see what the
user experience for our shopper is now
it's now not a great user experience I
think you'll agree so can we do a little
bit better than that can we work offline
well yes that's what our PWA api's are
going to let us do and the point of me
showing you this is really just because
blazer is a standard it's just using
standard
web technologies there's nothing special
or dependent on a server with it you can
use all the same PW air features that
you would from any other front-end
application so if we want to work
offline we can use something called a
serviceworker sustained a javascript api
and i've already got this serviceworker
file in my project here so that's a big
chunk of javascript and you might be
thinking hang on a minute
what this has meant to be a darknet
thing is it why are you now showing me
this massive block of JavaScript I don't
want to see that well I can sympathize
with that to some extent there's a good
reason why the serviceworker is best to
write in JavaScript and not in dotnet
and that's because a serviceworker runs
in a completely separate context to your
application it's not running as part of
your page at all so even though your
page normally has a dotnet runtime
inside it the serviceworker does not and
theoretically you could load up a dotnet
runtime inside your serviceworker if you
wanted but honestly this is 40 lines of
code is that too much and the other
thing is you don't really even have to
write these things yourself because
service workers are very boilerplate T
kind of things so if you go online and
you do a web search for a serviceworker
cookbook serviceworker boilerplate that
kind of thing you'll find lots of
examples of standard service workers
that other people have written that do
standard things like making your
application work offline so that's what
I've done here I've got this pretty much
boilerplate serviceworker
and I want to add a reference to it in
my application and the way you do that
is with a little bit of markup in your
host page so I'm gonna say okay browser
I want you to use the serviceworker
api's to register this serviceworker
here and now we've done that if we look
in the browser console and reload you'll
see it now says installing serviceworker
and that code is now going to run in a
separate context to my page and in fact
the browser will use it whenever it's
trying to make any network requests to
our domain so if I hit reload you'll see
every time there's a request to my
domain now we get these little messages
because I've put some logging inside
that serviceworker just to say we can
see that we're trying to make this
request and because that serviceworker
contains the logic to work offline to
cache all this stuff and replay it if
you can't reach the network let's see
what happens now if we are actually
offline so I'll press
this offline bone again and they'll hit
reload and this time we do not get the
error message in fact the application
just comes up and it works absolutely
fine so that's pretty cool
or is it well some of you may be
thinking hmm so Steve you think you're
very clever don't you making your
application works offline but you're not
clever
in fact what you've done is stupid and
pointless because what's gonna happen
now the user is gonna start walking
around the shop and they'll start
scanning groceries and what's going to
happen because you can't reach the
server can you okay I accept that is a
valid point so what's actually going to
happen in reality
so the users going to go around and
they're going to start scanning stuff so
I'll scan these beans and you can see we
cannot reach the server anymore so
that's sad boohoo but the good news is
we're still running all of our arbitrary
application logic here even though we're
offline we're still running Garnett code
and because there's a little bit of
retry logic in there if the user later
walks into an area of the shop where
they do have Wi-Fi access then even
without having to scan their stuff again
you'll see that it recovers and it fills
in the car and completes the operation
correctly so we haven't achieved a
miracle there we weren't able to reach
the server even while we were offline
but we have been able to make ourselves
reasonably resilient to certain kinds of
network outages which is the best I
think that you could realistically hope
to do so that's pretty nice ok what else
can we do with this people beware api's
well the other most famous thing that
you can do with them is you can make
your application installable so instead
of accessing it through a browser the
user can access it as if it was a
natively installed app on their Windows
Start menu their Mac dock or their
iPhone or Android home screens and
that's just a standard feature their
browsers and operating systems provide
to us so that's pretty good for us
because when our customers are shoppers
are using this app we don't want them to
think they're using a web browser we
don't want them to see an address bar
because you know they'll probably just
start using it for something totally
unrelated so we want it to feel like a
native up of its own so I'm going to do
that with one of these manifest files
standard PW err feature I'll give my
application a name define an icon and
some colors and stuff and then I'm going
to rent register that in my index.html
page
I'm going to use one of these link tags
like that and we'll see now what effect
that has on the application so just
before I reload I want you to watch
carefully see these two icons up here
well when I reload there's going to be a
third one so I hit reload and you can
see this little + fingers appeared now
and if you click on that it prompts us
do we want to install this into the
operating system and I'm gonna say yep I
sure do and that's now gonna pop up with
its own window it doesn't have a browser
address bar it's got its own color
themes and everything and it is a real
application it's our same application as
before and the user now if they want to
can find it from their Start menu like
that and that will come up on its own
and you know it really does work it has
all the functionality that we had before
so that's pretty nice so that is all I'm
gonna have time to tell you about when
it comes to this blazer mark thing so
we've been seeing how we can use some of
these things that we haven't actually
shipped yet to take a blazer webassembly
application and make it do cooler stuff
than you would normally be able to do
okay so let's now for the rest of the
talk try and broaden our minds a few
notches further because so far I've only
really told you about a couple of things
and there's actually a much bigger and
more exciting world out there so do you
remember back back in the day when we
had this slide earlier on in the talk
okay so I said that I would talk to you
about the differences between these two
models and and when you can use them
well the first question is have these
things even shipped yeah are these
supported products well the answer to
that is that for server-side Blaser yes
that has shipped that shipped as part of
dotnet Koryo which was out in
september/october ish last year so this
has been a shipped supported product for
about four months now so yes that is
absolutely a fully support thing for
client-side blaze a web assembly that is
currently still in preview but I know
it's been improved for absolutely ages
and yes we desperately want to actually
ship this we finally got an actual
committed release date it's not very far
away from now it's in May this year so
just a few more months to go until that
is shipped and supported as well okay so
the next question to ask is which of
these two models is
actually the right one for your
situation and before I answer that I
just want to really emphasize this key
point that you've got to get into your
mind which is it's not really an
either-or situation it's the same
programming model that's going to work
in both environments so if you buy into
the idea of building a blazer UI then
you can choose to run it on the server
or you can choose to run it on the
client you can start on the server and
move to the client you can start on the
client and move to the server you can
even in some crazy advanced cases create
an application that does both at once if
you want to so that's the flexibility
that you're getting by buying into this
pattern but still the question is which
one still is the one that you would
actually want to use well it depends on
your situation obviously so when it
comes to server-side Blaser that's going
to be the best choice for you if your
users have got a reliable low latency
connection to your server and the reason
why it's going to be the best in that
case is because it's much much simpler
you don't have to actually send the
dotnet runtime into the browser you
don't have to send your own code into
the browser everything's running on the
server in a much more predictable and
controlled environment and the UI
updates are just being streamed over the
wire down into the browser so that's a
very straightforward solution for you
and it means that you can work with very
low powered devices because they're not
really doing any significant work so
that's nice on the other hand the best
situation for doing client-side blair's
a web assembly is going to be in cases
where you want to not rely on access to
the server so if you want to actually
work offline then you absolutely need to
be running on webassembly Leykis there's
no server in that case or if you need to
have incredibly fast fine-grained UI
updates then blaze a web assembly is
going to be the best choice for you
there as well because you don't have to
wait for any traffic network traffic in
order to update the UI and the other
cool thing about blazer on webassembly
is to do with hosting so when you
publish your webassembly app there is no
specific server requirement it's just a
set of static files as far as your
server is concerned so you don't need
dotnet on the server you don't need
anything in particular on the server you
just need to be able to serve files so
you could host it on something like a
CDN or a blob store or anything else
like that and to prove that to you let
me show you in my browser now if I load
this bookmark
blazer Mart live you'll see that
actually opens my site just like before
and it
works just like before but have a look
at the URL there you'll see that this
has actually been hosted on github pages
which as you can understand is a very
very cheap way of hosting your
application it's free its globally
distributed and ablaze the webassembly
application can be served from that just
like it can be served from anywhere else
so that's one of the cool things okay
now so far I've only talked to you about
ways of running your application inside
a browser but Blaser is a more flexible
programming model than just that you can
run it in other places too what if you
didn't want to make something that
people load in their browser you don't
want to be subject to normal browser
sandbox limitations but you actually
want to make a native application
running regular native code and have
that pop up on a user's desktop for
example you won't want to build
something like an electron application
with Blaser well we've been doing quite
a bit of experimentation with that
recently and we've got some samples for
you to try out if you're interested so
we've got a sample of doing blazer with
electron we've got a sample of something
called web window which is like a very
lightweight alternative to electron it's
very experimental but it involves it
doesn't involve bundling a browser it
doesn't involve bundling node so it's a
much more lightweight way of bringing up
a desktop application that contains a
blazer UI if you want so see those
samples if you want and then in this
bottom right corner but there's
something even more future and elaborate
and we haven't really even done it yet
but I want to talk about anyway and so
what if we don't want to use web-based
rendering technology at all we don't
want to use HTML and CSS why if we
wanted to make a native mobile
application for iOS or Android or or
even a native desktop application and
instead of rendering through web
technologies we want to render native OS
components well we've got a sample of
that as well and just to really
emphasize neither the hybrid northern
native options are committed products
yet these are just experiments but we do
really want to get your feedback about
whether these things should be made into
real products and I want to show you an
example of something called mobile
blazer bindings which is a collaboration
between the xamarin team who mostly did
the work and the blazer team who just
get to take credit and I'll show you how
we
music to build a native iOS application
using blazer as a programming model so
let's switch back into the IDE for the
last time now and I'm gonna load
something called blazer mobile app which
is not the most creative name and inside
there you'll see I've got three projects
I've got blaze a mobile app which is a
blazer application so it contains a
bunch of razor files and c-sharp files
and it's the same programming model that
you know and love by now and we've also
got Android and iOS projects there is a
really any significant amount of coding
those two at the bottom they're just
little shell wrapper applications that
know how to start up on each of those
two operating systems and I'm gonna use
the iOS one right now so I'll show you
the code in a minute but first I want to
show you the app actually running so all
being well I'm gonna be able to make my
phone screen appear in front of your
just now let's see if this works okay
yeah very good okay so this is a iPhone
a normal iPhone you know them does all
the normal I for any things and I've
built this application here and deployed
it onto my phone so if I start that up
when that comes up that is not running
inside a browser there's no wk webview
or any other kind of browser rendering
technology this is native iOS elements
and we've got all the usual kind of demo
things in here so I've got this button I
can tap on it and it says how many times
I've clicked it I can move on to the
to-do list we'll do that in a minute and
we've got calculator so that's all just
being rendered using Blaser components
and it works cool what about this to-do
list well it's just you know the usual
industry standard to-do list that we
always have to show let's add some stuff
to the list so we'll have stuff okay and
I'm gonna tap on this Add button what
will it do
oh what a shocker what a disappointment
we haven't yet implemented the add item
feature which means we're going to have
to implement it just now as a demo okay
so let's have a look at some of the code
in this application well let's start
with this counter right here now if you
are familiar with the brave blaze a
programming model this should look
pretty familiar to you this is pretty
much the same as the web-based counter
with one kind of important difference so
inside the code block here we've got
exactly the same code as normal just
normal c-sharp code that's gotta count
in an increment count button and above
that we've got
markup but it's not HTML this time and
in fact I cannot use HTML even if I
wanted to because there is no browser
here the only thing I can use are these
native iOS elements and the ones I'm
using are this stack layout this label
and a button so we've got a label that
says how many times you've clicked and a
button that when you click it it cause
increment count and that behaves in
exactly the way that you think it should
okay and what about the to-do list well
there's a bit more going on with this
one let's just go through it step by
step okay so to get started with we've
got this to-do item class here with the
usual is done and text properties on it
we've got a list of to-do items and
we've got a new text string where the
user can enter some new text and up at
the top here we've got this entry which
is the thing that the xamarin team uses
to mean text box and we've bound that to
this new text field there and then I've
got a button that says when you click it
will call add item and inside on out add
item we're rendering this little popup
message so let's fill in an actual
implementation there so I'm going to say
to-do items dot add new to-do item and
we'll set the text on there to be the
new text okay and then I want the text
box to get cleared out so I'm going to
say a new text goes back to being its
default value of not okay
I also need to actually display these
items and because this is not zamel I
don't have to do any complicated stuff
with bindings or whatever if I want to
iterate over things and make a list well
I just go for each with normalcy shop
syntax for each item in to-do items I'm
going to render a to-do list item and
the thing that I'm going to pass to that
is the item okay very good so that's
pretty much all I have to do but I'm
just going to do one more thing because
I like to I'm going to also display the
number of items that have not been
completed yet so I'm gonna say we'll get
your to-do items and we'll count all the
ones in it for which the is done
property is still false okay now let's
try compiling that now and we'll see if
that actually builds and hopefully it
will it does okay now I've also got that
version of it on my phone as well so I'm
going to start that up
and we'll see what happens now so if I
go into this to-do list now and I start
entering something so I'm think this
time when I tap on the Add button you'll
see it does actually show up in my list
and I can do more things let's herb
laser is let's just do this third day
you get to the lobby okay cool that
makes total sense to me don't about you
and then I can start toggling these
buttons and it all works you see the the
number of dates as I do that and we have
all the usual scrolling and stuff so
we've been able to create a native
feeling iOS application using the blazer
programming model and without having to
use any sort of web rendering technology
okay so that is it that's all we have
time for today so I hope some of that
has been interesting and useful for you
if you want to learn more about this
stuff if you want to learn more about
blazer then go to blazer on net if you
want the code and the slides from this
talk then go to the URL that's up there
and you can download that and see that
for yourself so I hope that's been fun
and I hope you have a really good rest
of the conference thank you for coming
[Applause]